BOTH OF THEIR STORIES DIVERGE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR NEXT
ARTICLE AND I'LL TALK TO YOU
SOON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Brian: MEANWHILE, THE MEMO
NEWS SPARKED A TWITTER RESPONSE
FROM THE PRESIDENT.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW HE HAD A
TWITTER ACCOUNT.
JONATHAN TURLEY AS A LAWYER.
HE KNOWS THE ANSWER TO THAT.
PROFESSIONAL OF CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW AT GEORGE WASHINGTON
UNIVERSITY, OVER $70,000 A YEAR,
I LOOKED AT THAT WAY THEY DON'T
OFFER MUCH AID.
>> IT'S A DEAL.
>> Brian: YOU ARE THERE SO IT
MAKES IT WORTH IT.
WHAT DO WE LEARN NOW, JONATHAN,
THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW BEFORE THIS
BOOK PUBLISHED THAT HAS YOU
REALLY INTRIGUED?
>> IT CONFIRMS MANY THINGS THAT
SOME OF US HAVE BEEN SAYING.
FOR OVER A YEAR, YOU'VE HAD MANY
SUPPORTERS SAYING THINGS THAT I
THINK ARE FACIALLY SIMPLY
UNSUPPORTABLE.
ONE OF THEM IS THAT THESE WERE
SOME TYPE OF PERSONAL DIARY,
THAT THEY WERE HIS PERSONAL
NOTES.
HE CONTINUES TO MAINTAIN MATCH.
AND THAT IS FACIALLY RIDICULOUS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MEMOS, THEY
ARE NOT TO HIM, THEY ARE NOT MY
MOST OF THE FILE, THEY ARE MEMOS
TO OTHER FBI OFFICIALS.
HE IS ACTUALLY STATING IN ONE OF
THE MEMOS HOW HE WANTS TO DO THE
PRELIMINARY CLASSIFICATION AND
GIVING IT TO THESE OTHER
OFFICIALS FOR THEIR INPUT.
THESE ARE NOT PERSONAL RECORDS.
ALSO, THE FBI ITSELF HAS SAID,
THIS IS FBI MATERIAL.
SO YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO WAS
FIRED AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI, REMOVING SEVEN DOCUMENTS
FROM THE FBI, FOUR OF WHICH WERE
DEEMED TO HAVE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, AND THEN GIVING
THEM TO A FRIEND FOR THE PURPOSE
OF LICKING THEM TO THE MEDIA.
THAT IS A VERY SERIOUS SET OF
FACTS.
IT DOESN'T EXACTLY SPEAK TO THE
ETHICAL LEADERSHIP MODEL THAT
COMEY HAS BEEN A PROPONENT OF.
>> Brian: ONE PRESIDENT TRUMP
SINCE THERE IS THE BUSINESSMAN
TURNED BRAND-NEW POLITICIAN AND
SAYS, WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
COMEY?
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH McCABE?
PETER STRZOK, LISA PAGE.
YES, YES, YES, AND YES.
HIS INSTINCTS WERE RIGHT ON
THIS!
>> I THINK THAT IT WOULDN'T
COMES TO COMEY, MANY OF THE
CRITICISMS HAVE BEEN BORNE OUT,
AS WITH McCABE.
NOT THAT THE PRESIDENT HASN'T
MADE HIS OWN MISTAKES BUT HE HAS
BEEN BLESSED BY THE CRITICS THAT
HE HAS INHERITED.
I THINK WITH REGARD TO McCABE,